what's up guys Bryan Callen my arch
nemesis has a show here in Phoenix
Arizona now I live in Los Angeles but I
heard that they wanted him to do an hour
here at the celebrity theater and since
I know he doesn't have an hour of
material I came to help him out and I'm
gonna run onstage and ambush the show
and take it up a level this is the truth
he has no idea I'm here let's see what
happens
[Music]
[Applause]
pants
[Music]
[Applause]
we do start it takes nobody knows where
and I live in Los Angeles
[Applause]
I hurt bride who's going to be doing is
showing feelings did you really think
anything about the balls is right
[Applause]
because you know what really drives fast
[Music]
nice
[Applause]
[Music]
the video game character when you first
get it
I do want to say this
your obsession
[Music]
[Applause]
don't see your hair okay
[Music]
[Applause]
my first
it's like
[Music]
the only advice particulars by one
admirer like Jimmy Neutron Aslam
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
all right but on this I just wanted to
surprise you and I wanted to ask you to
give you some of the money right because
I can
[Music]
[Applause]
he has a different show right it's one
school those seven people see
[Applause]
[Music]
my best friend
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
Scarah amazing no you guys want to do
cocaine because there's not a second
other papers